[Applause]
Arms forces of the Russian Federation
continue a special operation in
Ukraine of fighter aviation of the
Russian Aerospace Forces in the area of ​​​​Kramatorsk Donetsk of the
People's Republic
of Ukraine shot down a Su-25 aircraft of the Ukrainian Air Force
In addition, Russian
air defense systems shot down a
Mi 8 helicopter of the Ukrainian Air Force in the area of
Pervomaisk, Mykolaiv region,
includes two  a year ago, it turns out that I
graduated from school and it’s very sad that
it happened
this way, I think I didn’t want to fully
realize that this is our reality, a
good school, but do the director, this
school invested a lot of money to
tell and put my soul into it, and now the
Russian meta to say
in explosions one later  the second one I didn’t
hear the most, the ceiling everything falls on me
all the furniture everything is like a mole you forgot to
take out the nets you or hide from your
wife alive everything got out the same way myself
well
let’s see everything here everything is
just unbanned for everything when I flood there were
rottenness of the school for this  everyone sat down herself and
sprinkled with us, you know, she  right away we didn’t
understand, we asked for something else in
some kind of fog,
but it
started to climb out, I
didn’t believe it, I thought it was rivalda, but when
it failed, I still wanted to live with
these hands, everyone pulled out like a
cavity of a mushroom, not all of the channel